[Music]
nope no it was dope man Snooper said to
meet him Jermaine for some dinner so you
know I understand that Jermaine's a
little frustrated by the studio so I'm
excited and when we get together this
always a great time it's not right here
at the table right here man this is 27
years alone right here right before I
had kids he was my son and that's that's
just what it is it's the same with JD
I've seen how he raised you like he put
his career on pause for you know that
you got to get people to start thinking
that Bala is grown yes yeah you wanna
share you gotta come out this house I'm
definitely alright as you are while you
be hanging on my come on lean no I got
this yes this month is my turn now I
don't believe you working hard enough
[Music]
you're driving the colony in first and
second it's three mo gears and then
comes a net now that right there makes
sense I knew this was gonna happen they
invited me I don't think we're gonna be
on some play it but instead they getting
on my about the music
let it come when it comes
[Music]
you